said krankenhäuser mitten im central
park und genau dort steht jetzt mein
bild kollege herbert bauernebel herbert
erzählt uns ein bisschen über die zelte
hinter dir dann öffnen die und wie viele
patienten sollen dort dann untergebracht
werden
ja also hinter mir sieht man eine zelt
anlage die von einer christlichen
hilfsorganisation american sports hier
gebaut wurde im ikonischen central park
das alleine ist irgendwie bereits ein
sehr außergewöhnliche situation in
diesen zelten hinter mir sollen dann in
den nächsten tagen oder bereits ab heute
wenn die ersten patienten kommen
corona virus patienten behandelt werden
dieses feldlazarett ist komplett
ausgestattet mit allen geräten die an
die man normalerweise auf einer
intensivstation findet und es gibt hier
beatmungsgeräte es gibt hier ärzte die
von der hilfsorganisation zur verfügung
gestellt wurden krankenschwestern ein
komplettes team auch mit einer eigenen
stromversorgung und insgesamt 60 betten
sollen hier zur verfügung gestellt
werden die ersten patienten wie gesagt
werden heute nachmittag erwartet und
durch dieses feldlazarett sollen die new
yorker spitäler entlastet werden wo die
situation natürlich extrem kritisch ist
bereits warum herbert ausgerechnet im
central park hätte es noch andere orte
gegeben warum an diesem ort der ja ja
für die new yorker so wichtig ist zur
erholung und auch ein bisschen gewissen
symbol wert hat also warum ausgerechnet
dort zum einen muss man sagen dass ein
staat ist groß genug um raum zu haben
für solche erzählt städte so ein
feldlazarett und der grund für die
location hier ist da ganz einfach
gegenüber der straße auf der anderen
seite ist dass man sein haus betont
eines der größeren spitäler von new york
und dort ist der platz bereits eng
deshalb sollen viele dieser patienten
jetzt eben einfach ausgelagert werden in
diese in dieses feldlazarett hier im
central park für die new yorker ist es
natürlich eine schon erstaunliche szene
ihren geliebten park jetzt so zu sehen
mit weißem sanitätszelten herbert
ist new york im moment deiner auffassung
noch herr der lage das sind ja wirklich
drastische bilder einmal hinter dir
diese zeltstadt für corona patienten
dann haben wir gesehen dieses sanitäts
schiff dieses riesige schiff das zuletzt
nach nine eleven angelegt hat vor
manhattan das jetzt vor die stadt
gefahren ist und daneben auch diese
bilder von leichensäcken und
gabelstapler die die leichen dort
stapeln ist new york herr der lage oder
mittlerweile überfordert man muss sagen
derzeit möglicherweise noch herr der
lage die situation in den spitälern ist
angespannt aber noch nicht
systemkritisch die meisten patienten
werden hier eigentlich noch normal
versorgt aber natürlich aufgrund der
hohen anzahl der toten der s 1000
menschen sind im beige book gestorben
da kommt es zu wirklich makaberen
grauenhaften szenen wo gleichen einfach
abtransportiert werden aus dem spital um
dann in einen kühllaster gelegt werden
aber insgesamt derzeit die situation
kritisch noch nicht ganz glücklich aber
angespannt aber natürlich der höhepunkt
der carola virusinfektionen hier in new
york wird in zwei bis drei wochen
erwartet
und dann natürlich wären alle new yorker
spitäler völlig überrannt um deshalb
versuchen die offiziellen und auch der
gouverneur des staates new york andrew
cuomo zu viel extra betten wie möglich
hier zu schaffen ganz ganz eine andere
kurze kurze sache andrew cuomo bruder
chris cooper des ie9 enke wurde heute
gerade mit dem corona virus positiv
getestet hier sieht man wie weit
verbreitet dieses virus hier in new york
ist es recht wirklich alle von spitals
mitarbeitern bis sie einen moderatorin